ce magnifique match de speechers entre
Carsen et Yann nepomyachi alors
malheureusement je vais être obligé de
bricoler un petit truc parce que Yann
c'est un remplaçant de dernière minute
et j'ai pas son nom je me suis rendu
compte en fait il y a tout un tas
[Musique]
on va faire un truc moche
il y a c'est un remplaçant la minute et
il y avait tout un tas de design joli
et du coup et du coup pour Yann on l'a
pas donc je vais organiser un petit truc
qui sera pas super beau certes
mais qui permettra d'avoir le nom bon on
fait ce qu'on peut à le match a commencé
à attendez la partie c'est pas lancé
un petit bug je suis désolé et on va on
est parti pour un peu plus de 9h
ensemble là de speechers
ça va être extraordinaire alors attendez
la partie se lance pas il y a réellement
un bug j'ai réellement un bug je suis
désolé
j'arrive pas à me connecter à chaise
comme
ça va venir
j'arrive à avoir l'accueil
ça c'est déjà pas mal
ça y est on a les parties ben magnifique
je vais maintenant vous ouvrir le chat
et puis on va être là alors après je
vais commenter tranquille parce que 9h30
de commentaire consécutifs c'est pas
facile j'aurais pas assez d'énergie pour
tout faire avec la voix etc jusqu'au
bout donc tranquille on va regarder le
premier match de manière plus tranquille
parce que 9h30 d'affilée c'est j'ai plus
l'âge en fait pour faire ça surtout avec
la petite j'ai plus le sommeil
nécessaire donc chill très très chill là
le 1er match on s'embarras si c'est
intéressant moi je pense que le match
sera pas serré du tout je pense qu'il y
a on a absolument rien à faire surtout
vu son tweet d'hier
donc ouais
c'est pas que je pense et que j'en suis
absolument certain surtout qui joue de
jour d'affilée donc je pense ça va pas
être un match
hyper intéressant enfin on verra mais
enfin pas intéressant pas serré quoi
pour être plus précis de toute façon
vous avez la chose à gauche
donc c'est parfait
mais je pense pas que ce soit un match
serré quoi
c'est quoi son tweet ah bah il est pas
grosso modo pour le raccourcir il est
pas très heureux des règles anti triche
grosso modo il est il est pas très pas
très content des règles anti triche sur
le tournoi
ouais après on a bien compris de toute
façon c'est un fléau contre lequel il
est difficile de lutter
je pense pas moi personnellement je
pense qu'il y a pas de règle
aujourd'hui
en mesure alors pourquoi on n'a pas le
temps des Noirs ah ouais attendez
attendez attendez un truc qui va pas
voir la c'est ça en fait c'est que ça
m'a tout voilà je me suis fait
déconnecté de tout
désolé c'est pour ça que l'écran était
mal réglé désolé c'est le petit bug qui
m'a fait mal voilà maintenant on est
bien ouais de toute façon il y a pas de
règle aujourd'hui en capacité de
d'assurer une sécurité si les gens sont
chez eux donc en quelque sorte
si tu acceptes de jouer dans un
événement en ligne
c'est que
tu acceptes qu'il soit possible enfin
c'est inhérent on peut pas surveiller
les gens chez eux de toute façon quoi
qu'on fasse il y aura toujours moyen et
matière à
enfin voilà quoi
donc je vois pas trop ce qui vient faire
enfin faut juste ne pas participer ne
pas jouer et puis et puis c'est tout en
fait
donc je suis pas complètement d'accord
avec Yann sur sur ce truc là
c'est un peu ce que disait Carlson
carvana cramique ouais moi je pense que
moi c'est ma vision des choses en fait
si les joueurs sont chez eux ils peuvent
tricher c'est facile enfin c'est facile
c'est pas facile mais c'est possible on
peut rien y faire du moment que tu
acceptes de jouer en tournant en ligne
c'est que tu acceptes qui est une
probabilité importante d'avoir quelqu'un
qui triche contre toi et point barre en
fait pourra jamais vérifier c'est comme
faire passer des examens à des gens chez
eux
comment veux-tu c'est il y a pas de
manière en fait c'est juste impossible
donc tu acceptes que la probabilité soit
importante mais du coup les résultats
n'ont aucune importance aussi enfin
c'est pas c'est pas grave quoi
c'était juste une blague je pense pas il
y a même mis caru qui a réagi au tweet
sur sur sa chaîne etc donc non c'est pas
juste une blague mais
juste dans un certain côté c'est un peu
déplacé quoi
mais très franchement
le casque ça change rien enfin je verrai
avec ou sans casque c'est extrêmement
facile
la réaction me fait plaisir bah les Caro
en gros
il dit que il devrait pas faire ce genre
d'insination sur Twitter et qu'il a qu'à
lire les règles parce que les casques
sont autorisés
grosso modo c'est ça la réponse du
carreau et il Caro il a complètement
raison et là-dessus je peux pas lui
donner tort
c'est
c'est vrai en fait c'est autorisé mais
voilà enfin c'est
mais du coup faut donner aucune
importance à ses compétitions en termes
de niveau de jeu tu peux gagner 100 fois
ça va rien dire enfin c'est ça que je
veux dire c'est du moment où c'est aussi
facile on peut pas donner d'importance
c'est pas possible
les gars sont autorisés c'est pas ou
c'est pas interdit les deux en fait on a
le droit de les mettre et vu qu'il y a
des arbitres avant le match qui viennent
vérifier il pourrait très bien
signifier qu'on a pas le droit mais
c'est pas on a le droit
donc
enfin voilà je donne 100% raison à Ikaru
sur sur le truc
il faut lire les les règles des
compétitions auxquelles ont participé et
vu les règles enfin et vu le fait que ce
soit Full Internet ou quoi il donnait
absolument zéro importance et point
barre
si aucune importance c'est pas vrai la
porte non pas du tout je suis sur
internet en fait c'est comme ça ça peut
pas avoir d'importance
ça peut pas en fait vu qu'il y a pas de
règlement qui permet
d'assurer la sécurité du truc
bah tu comptes sur le
sur l'honnêteté de ton adversaire et la
majorité des joueurs sont honnêtes donc
ça c'est pas c'est pas un problème mais
si quelqu'un se ma batte tout le monde
sur internet ça veut pas dire qu'il est
plus fort que les autres en fait
ça veut rien dire
c'est tout
c'est tout donc on peut voir c'est
c'est comme ça tu regardes tu kiffes tu
vois des belles parties mais
[Musique]
ça va pas plus loin quoi faut pas faut
pas trop se prendre au sérieux
en tout cas il fait un bon début de
partie
si aucune grosse tête ne prête attention
à cette tournoi il y aura du changement
pas avant
je comprends pas trop
ce que tu veux dire les joueurs ils
viennent jouer ils prennent des gros
chats
donc ils ont raison de jouer il y a pas
de souci mais il faut qu'il joue enfin
faut qu'il joue un peu un peu comme ça
quoi genre tu viens bah comme là il
clique Carlsen tête je sais pas Yann
peut-être il triche pas enfin on n'en
sait rien on espère que non pareil
pareil pour Carlsen mais tu auras jamais
une garantie à 100% et donc il faut pas
donner plus d'importance que ça au
délire c'est tout quoi
ça va pas plus loin tu viens tu prends
ton chèque tu es content et puis tu
repars
ni plus ni moins quoi
j'ai une galère en tout cas la finale
elle va être nulle
n'est pas de logiciels
que permet de voir le PC et si jamais
j'ai quelqu'un qui me souffle les coups
là la pièce dans la pièce d'à côté
comment tu vas le voir
comment tu vas savoir s'il y a quelqu'un
derrière qui qui souffle les coups
impossible en fait tu peux pas il y a
trop de manières comment tu sais si j'ai
pas un truc qui vibre dans ma chaussure
pendant la partie pour me dire que j'ai
un coup à trouver enfin il y a trop de
manières il y a c'est impossible c'est
impossible de régler le problème c'est
c'est impossible c'est pas une question
de mauvaise
de mauvaises intentions quoi que ce soit
c'est juste que tu ne peux pas en fait
il y a un inconvénient à faire des
placeurs arbitre chez chaque joueur mais
ça coûte hyper cher faut que ce soit
quelqu'un qui soit dans notre pays
qui connaissent pas bien le joueur ça va
te coûter tellement cher
ah ça s'appelle une pièce Magnus
terrible ouais il a pas l'air dans son
assiette en ce début de match Magnus on
va voir
je vous ai mis côté Magnus pour le match
alors on va mettre les scores à jour
ça c'est un
et là c'est zéro
non là c'est 1 et c'est de l'autre côté
le 0 pardon
tellement l'habitude de voir Magnus
gagner
il joue contre Carole gagnant sera le
gagnant du match ce soir qui joue contre
car ou ça ça jouera contre sceaux
ce qu'on voit ici va jouer contre eux
je suis dans une galère là je sais pas
pourquoi
je suis dans la race là je suis dans la
race la plus totale
perso je regardais pas les temps avec
ouais enfin je sais pas honnêtement
je sais pas trop quoi dire
en tout cas le problème je pense qu'il
est vraiment insoluble il y a pas je
vois je vois vraiment très très
franchement pour avoir retourné le
problème dans ma tête de tous les sens
possible je vois aucune solution je
pense qu'il y a réellement pas de
solution
la solution c'est la becap ouais mais du
coup la solution c'est de
c'est d'être dans un lieu mais je veux
dire avec des gens chez eux seuls je
j'ai beau retourner le problème dans
tous les sens je vois pas de solution
mais réellement pas en fait
solution ce que dans son truc c'est du
semis distantiel ouais mais ça c'est ce
qu'on fait déjà c'est la beck-up en fait
bixented je veux je parle dans ce format
là précis où tu veux garder les joueurs
chez eux tranquille pour qu'ils puissent
jouer en calbute et prendre 50 cas la
semaine en étant en cas de but de chez
eux ce truc là je vois pas de solution
pour
pour garantir la sécurité de l'événement
je vois pas qu'elle méthode pour être
mise en place c'est pour ça qu'en fait
le truc du casque pas casque
au final
ça change pas grand chose
cette façon si tu veux tricher tu
tricheras en fait
on voyait un orbite à la maison
peut-être ouais mais bon si à chaque
fois en arbitre ça te coûte 2 ou 3000 €
parce qu'il faut qu'ils prennent des
vols etc ben ils auront moins de prix et
du coup ils auront plus il y aura moins
d'argent et donc ils joueront plus donc
tu reportes le problème sur un autre sur
autre chose
et puis bon il y a l'arbitre à la maison
machin dans tous les cas il faudrait
mieux que ce soit dans un lieu neutre
quoi qu'il en soit
mais du moment que tu es chez toi je
vois pas comment on peut
je sais pas les carreaux sur son live il
disait enfin sur sa vidéo j'ai écouté on
a une caméra devant une caméra derrière
ouais alors en fait enfin
je comprends c'est ça limite mais je
vois pas à quel moment c'est ok tu as
une caméra devant une caméra derrière
ouais ok
non mais c'est bien ça évite les trucs
vraiment d'une facilité déconcertante
mais bon là avec un casque dans
l'oreille tu as juste fait un trou dans
le casque tu rajoutes un
une mini oreillette enfin si tu prends
le casque tu ce que j'ai un casque
devant devant moi ouais tu prends tu
prends tu prends ton casque là tu fais
un petit trou tu mets quelque chose à
l'intérieur tu mets ton casque dessus à
personne qui verra rien tu montes ton
casque personne ne va jamais remarquer
hein je veux dire c'est d'une facilité
des concertante
c'est enfin c'est même pas que c'est
facile c'est que ça prend 10 minutes en
fait c'est tu mets 10000 à construire le
truc
genre c'est pas que c'est facile c'est
que
mais bon si tu interdit les casques que
je vais trouver une autre manière qui va
prendre 10 minutes aussi en fait je vais
te cacher quelque chose dans un vêtement
enfin il y a 10 000 manières en fait
c'est trop facile
tu vois là je vais avoir mon col de
vêtements il va être il va être cousu
ici et là je vais avoir un truc qui fait
qui me dit les coups
après il disait qu'il y avait 30
secondes de lag bah 30 secondes de lag
je vais cacher une caméra dans un de mes
livres derrière dans ma bibliothèque
une à une nano caméra je vais la cacher
derrière ça va filmer mon écran
et le gars il sera connecté en wifi
voilà merci au revoir 30 minutes de
préparation je me prépare un vêtement
marlou et je me mets une caméra cachée
dans mon décor que tu pourras jamais
détecter puisque tu es pas dans la salle
terminé merci au revoir c'est ciao
instantané en fait
et là j'ai même pas réfléchi et c'est un
détectable et c'est hyper facile donc en
sens ça je suis pas d'accord avec Yann
Le casque n'est pas un problème
ça facilite les choses mais ça facilite
un truc qui de toute façon est très
facile
qu'un arbitre puisse venir chez toi à
tout le monde contrôler ouais enfin bon
tu vas être sûr tu viens chez moi tu vas
être reçu frérot
tu peux voir les connexions présentes
sur un PC ouais mais là j'ai pas besoin
de connexion présente sur mon pc Arnaud
de chasse et monitor le PC mais ma nano
machin mon petit ma petite oreillette
elle est pas connectée au PC
et ma caméra non plus je suis jamais
connecté à mon pc en fait
mais je suis pas connecté à mon wifi
j'ai un modem 4G
donc non pas tu vas tu peux avoir
connexion à mon wifi ou quoi tu dis il y
a pas de solution Arnaud de chasse faut
arrêter il faut pas être élu il y a pas
de solution au problème donc au final
le casque ne me choque pas je suis
d'accord avec ma caméra je suis pas
choqué par le casque
la seule chose où je suis pas d'accord
avec Nakamura le seul moment où je suis
pas d'accord avec kikoo c'est dire ah
ouais il y a une caméra devant il y a
une caméra derrière pour moi ça ne
change rien
c'est pas dur de voir toutes les
connexions ouvertes dans une pièce alors
comment tu vas savoir que j'ai un 4G en
fait Arnaud de chasse
par quelle magie tu vas savoir que je
suis connecté en 4G sur sur d'autres
non mais bon enfin soit soit d'élus et
pense que tu peux empêcher les gens de
tricher depuis chez eux et puis et puis
voilà
tu vas réussir tu vas réussir là de chez
toi de chez toi là tu peux tu peux avoir
tu peux savoir comment comment je suis
connecté chez moi là comme ça là
c'est c'est
la NASA le frère
je leur fais rien de gueule mais bon ce
que tu veux il trouveront toujours une
solution en fait un autre chasse il y
aura toujours une solution en fait
tu auras toujours une solution il y a
tellement d'argent en jeu
donc voilà c'est pour ça que je suis
plus ou moins d'accord avec icaru
sauf sur le côté caméra en mode ah ouais
j'ai deux caméras allumées chez moi
ouais bon ok enfin
après je pense
ultimement il y aura aucun moyen
d'empêcher la triche ben je crois que on
va en venir comme l'histoire en fait
l'esport pour empêcher la triche il joue
plus depuis chez eux c'est en fait c'est
aussi simple que ça faut partir c'est
pour ça que je dis Yann il a pas raison
faut partir du principe du moment que tu
es chez toi triche possible pas autorisé
par encourager
mais possible et point barre
mais d'ailleurs ouais il y a plus aucun
eSport qui fait comme les échecs et qui
laisse les gens chez eux ça n'existe
plus pour les compétitions importantes
ça n'existe plus en fait là il y a
tellement d'argent
ça existe plus causer chaque on est
toujours en retard
c'est comme ça c'est pas c'est pas grave
mais
en histoire tu fais des qualifères
depuis chez toi mais toutes les phase
finale sont en présentiel ouais mais aux
échecs
c'est les phases finales qui sont online
je joue pas mal Yann là quand même
il va s'en sortir Yann qui sait
peut-être qui va gagner ce serait
surprenant mais faire un bon début de
match en tout cas
en vrai il y a beaucoup d'espoirs qui
n'ont pas les moyens de faire du
présentiel ouais mais les eSports avec
des prices pool sur les saisons à deux
trois millions d'euros ils sont ils sont
présentiel faut comparer ce qui est
comparable
le truc récent c'est que les premières
lignes sont souvent les mêmes qu'en réel
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec ça
non plus mais
tu peux avoir un second PC qui tourne il
y a pas d'antitude qui fonctionne pour
les échecs et les échecs c'est beaucoup
plus difficile en plus à contrôler que
les autres espoirs ouais c'est plus
difficile ouais
parce que ton cheat il est pas
obligatoirement sur ton ordi donc ça ça
rend plus le truc nettement plus dur
c'est moi ou Carlson a pris part à
autant de tournois depuis qu'il a besoin
de son titre champion du monde en fait
chaque expack il joue beaucoup sur
Internet Carlson et comme il y a de plus
en plus de tournoi sur internet il joue
de plus en plus
déjà compétit pour moi la triche
c'est le danger numéro 1 et
la prise de conscience est assez longue
c'est bon sur Internet
il a essayé il a fait un truc assez
malin en fait
il tape les gens que si trouchent contre
lui en fait il est pas vraiment contre
la triche il triche il lutte contre la
triche contre lui
donc du moment qui pense qui considère
que contre lui les gens ont trop peur de
tricher ça lui convient enfin c'est mon
interprétation
et je parle de sentiments je parle pas
de triche réalité
que ça triche pas contre lui je pense
que ça lui va
ce que je peux comprendre
ça aurait dû H4 écoute je sais pas on va
voir hein
ça peut ça peut c'est pas comment ça
joue là je pense pas
j'ai du mal à comprendre
ouais c'est sur une conviction
personnelle très très forte après
on peut dire que ça a été efficace quand
même
une propositions intéressantes ouais bah
ça commence par le beaucoup avec mvl de
façon ça reprend beaucoup de choses
qu'on a essayé qu'on essaie de mettre en
place dans nos événements
notamment d'ailleurs sous l'influence de
ml
qui a complètement raison
mais ce qu'ils font comprendre et c'est
un peu le problème sur lequel revient
maxi mais aussi un petit peu car roana
en réalité ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est qu'on sait pas qui triche ni quand
mais ce qu'on sait c'est que c'est
facile à faire et qui a des gens qui le
font en gros
en gros c'est ça on sait pas qui ni
quand mais on sait que ça se fait
et donc et donc il faut ouais il va
falloir évoluer un jour ou l'autre
tu peux pas savoir
qui sont fait prendre donc on suppose
que d'autres riches aussi en gros oui et
puis il y a des incohérences dans les
parties dans les résultats il y a trop
de trucs bizarres pour que
statistiquement
ce soit possible
c'est juste tu as trop de trucs qui sont
hautement improbable
pour que
pour qu'on ait aucun dans le tas qui
soit lié à la triche en fait c'est plus
ça
donc c'est plus ça c'est pour ça si on
s'est Niki ni quand parce que ça va tu
as plein de trucs qui sont proches d'un
possible genre
mais
voilà quoi
n'est pas utile pour l'instant ouais
absolument rien à [__] ça lui salut
combien bien ça le fait rire
quels sont les joueurs sont toi qui
trichent au vu des résultats incohérents
que toi tu as pu voir
ça je peux pas dire du coup j'ai pas le
droit
mais après comme je dis il y a aucun
joueur sur lequel je suis sûr à 100% en
fait ça peut aller varier de
même aller des fois jusqu'à 95% mais
c'est jamais vraiment sans tu penses
mais tu es pas sûr quoi
même Magnus on n'est pas sûr alors sur à
100 % je le serai jamais de personne non
plus ça aussi c'est un truc intelligent
qui avait dit Maxime c'est qu'il y a que
lui qui peut être sûr de lui en fait
sinon tu es obligé d'être en fait il
faut avoir une attitude où tu as
toujours du doute donc oui tu dois
douter de tout le monde en tout cas sur
internet à 100% sûr
ça c'est sûr tu dois vraiment être avoir
ce côté doute
permanent et après suivant la cohérence
ou l'incohérence des résultats
va augmenter cette part de doute quoi
mais ouais la vidéo de cramique pour
l'avoir vu je la trouve moi
personnellement assez naze
cependant elle traduit un réel malaise
encore une nul ouais
parce que la position était vraiment
nul depuis un long moment
on espère que les choses vont évoluer en
tout cas il y a clairement un malaise
qui grandit chez les joueurs au fur et à
mesure
et je pense qu'il y a trois camps de
joueurs
en fait pour moi ça divise un peu en
trois camps pour le moment ceux qui
triche on peu importe
ceux qui trichent pas mais qui sont
contents de du confort de jouer depuis
chez eux et de prendre quand même de la
caillasse parce qu'il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de caillasses dans les
tournants en ligne et vu que maintenant
même vous voyez bien sur les play-in de
chaise comme et tout il y a trois
divisions il y a de l'argent à gagner de
partout donc ils disent bon même si ça
triche un peu de vent
je m'en balai parce que je prends quand
même pas mal de caillasses en restant en
cas de but de chez moi donc ça me
convient donc il y a ceux qui trichent
ceux qui sont fichent parce qu'ils se
disent bon au final de toute façon je
prends quand même ma caillasse et il y a
ceux qui veulent vraiment faire avancer
les choses parce que de mon point de vue
ils comprennent que c'est un poison qui
qui va tuer le jeu
lentement mais sûrement
mais en fait je pense qu'il y a vraiment
trois
catégories de joueurs
tu as vu cette position historique j'en
ai aucune idée je suppose que oui vu la
vitesse de jeu
il y a bien un jour ils vont faire
quelque chose de toute façon moi je
pensais que ça arriverait plus vite
franchement je pensais qu'il y aurait
quelque chose de fait depuis déjà
plusieurs
plusieurs années je pensais que le
l'affaire Animan ce serait le dernier
électrochoc en fait mais depuis la ferme
il s'est pas passé grand chose au final
ouais les gens qui regardent on en
discutait ça pareil avec Maxime genre la
voix Maxime il a rage quitte moi aussi
j'ai le seum de la Vuelta là c'est trop
mais c'est à peu près la stratégie
actuelle aussi dans les échecs c'est
motus et bouche cousue ouais
mais le public n'est pas du pain faut
pas prendre le public pour des abrutis
le public se rend compte qu'il y a des
problèmes
j'ai même pas je sais même pas si il a
gardé son maillot rouge cette caisse
j'ai même pas regardé en fait là
mais même moi en fait j'étais hyper hype
par la Vuelta et tout beau parcours
c'était sympa j'étais mais bon là c'est
ok ça dégoûté en fait
autant que ça avait dégoûté le contrôle
à la montre du Tour de France ou quoi
mais au bout d'un moment ça s'accumule
et le public n'est pas du pays quitte
à la différence du cyclisme qui a quand
même plus de ménage qui est fait de
temps en temps il met un grand coup de
balai
dans le vélo
aux échecs on a même pas ça quoi
il y a plus d'étapes de montagne là
c'est fini je vous dis j'ai vraiment
rage quitte le l'événement
enfin c'est compliqué on verra on verra
comment les choses évoluent en tout cas
ce match pour le moment on l'a pas suivi
à fond encore mais il est long comme je
vous ai dit comme il y a deux matchs
consécutif aujourd'hui 9h30 de
commentaires je me sens pas de regarder
les toutes les game à fond pendant 9h30
c'est un peu beaucoup
donc on va on va monter en puissance
avec le match et on va regarder plus
tranquillement
le 5 + 5 et on se chauffera plus à
partir du 3 + 1 et du 1 + 0
9h30 de commentaires c'est vraiment
beaucoup
l'autre match ce sera donc on va essayer
d'être vraiment concentré pas de se
dégoûter des échecs avant le truc de ML
quoi
ouais on fait en mode chill non mais je
sais qu'après je me fais tomber dessus
sur Youtube machin il commande pas tous
les coups etc donc je préfère le dire
mais c'est juste pas humain d'analyser
des échecs
à fond pendant plus de 9 heures
enfin c'est peut-être humain mais moi je
j'ai pas les
capacités de le faire
bon ce qui me rassure c'est que Baki
l'autre jour après une heure et demie ou
deux heures il était déjà à bout de
souffle
ce format speech donc
c'est une telle machine que Baki à bout
de souffle c'est que
c'est que c'est pas évident
pas aussi naturel que mvl ouais c'est
surtout que c'est pas c'est un peu long
quoi on va pas se mentir le 5 + 5 est
vraiment long
ça fait pas une grosse différence au
score et ça dure quand même avec la pose
une heure 50 voire deux heures c'est
vraiment long
et c'est narole d'ordi c'est plus facile
alors après pour un peu avoir regardé
les commentaires je fais plus de quel
match que je commentais pas
ils avaient aussi pour des américains
ils avaient énormément de mal à Seilles
il faisait un peu tiep même
ils étaient pas hyper emballé par le
match
c'était c'est simple c'était karwana
Naka je l'ai trouvé pas giga
vu qui se surraille à chaque fois pour
pour un oui pour un non
je l'ai trouvé pas vraiment hype
connaissant les loustiques j'étais
étonné
mais après je les comprends aussi dans
le sens où c'est quand même
systématiquement les mêmes affiches donc
au bout d'un moment tu suis un peu quoi
mais ouais ils étaient moins fringants
qu'habituellement je sais pas si vous
avez suivi le match si vous avez eu la
même opinion que moi mais je l'ai trouvé
nettement moins fringant que d'habitude
après j'ai pas je vous mens pas j'ai pas
regardé très longtemps parce que le
match me semblait sans intérêt j'ai vu
deux ouvertures troll de Naka le casque
sur les oreilles bon ok
ça a été vite vite ciao aussi
côté streamer
marrant de cette partie ce qui va
réussir
c'était pas un beau match quoi
ce qui va réussir avec les noirs
capitaliser sur ses pions qui avance
sûrement la jauge j'aime bien
les noirs
il veut défendre comme ça mais je crois
qu'après il veut tourner
mais le problème c'est qu'il est keblo
là c'est très bien joué de la part de
Carlsen pour le coup
ça va elle va faire mal à Yann
je crois qu'on va déjà avoir une
première pause s'il joue encore pendant
40 secondes
pour avoir une première pause qui va
faire du bien bien défendu ça de la part
de Yann ce qui va essayer de repasser sa
tour de l'autre côté
pour pousser son pion
ça doit perdre mais c'est pas mal tenté
la mettre quelques échecs pour faire
passer le roi devant le pion
ah mais il va faire tout deux
tellement bien joué de la part de Magnus
mais c'est bien ça va nous amener
jusqu'à la pause
bien joué
très bien joué de la part de Magnus
allez petite pause de
de 7 minutes on se retrouve on se
retrouve dans 7 minutes les amis
vous les streamer des échecs comme vous
créateurs préférés tels que be stream
Naka ou les
soeurs.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimentés
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience en connectant
votre compte à cheese.com et profiter de
la visibilité offerte alors d'autres
plateforme de jeu il vous suffit de
relier votre compte à
cheese.com/settings
mettre échec comme catégorie sur twitch
et commencer à streamer
d'une expérience sans publicité sur
chaise.com et apparaître et dans notre
liste de streamer en direct votre profil
affichera votre stream twitch qui sera
aussi mis en avant durant vos parties
offert utiliser la commande community
streamer dans le chat et faites grossir
votre audience sans plus attendre
[Musique]
voilà les gars j'ai une très mauvaise
nouvelle je me suis fait matrixer par la
pub chascom
et j'ai lancé une game de clash royale
matrixé par la pub
c'est terrible pour moi
je suis matrixé par la pub
ah c'est la pub pièces comme
range pour rien dire
si je fais si je fais un clash Royal
pendant pendant les commentaires
je me suis fait publicitaire
en plus je me fais défoncer c'est ça le
pire
il est en train de faire super mal
c'est terrible
matrix
j'ai perdu ma game matrixé par la pub
mais elles font mal alors plus belle
elles sont très bien d'ailleurs je vous
les recommande les puces comme elles
étaient assez sympa je me referai un
clash royale après
ah c'était belle game
ils font vraiment de très très belles
pubs
ah mais là je vous ai pas raconté j'ai
failli mourir tout à l'heure
ah mais c'est terrible aujourd'hui en
fait j'ai failli crever
j'ai failli me faire écraser tout à
l'heure en traversant la rue la route
j'ai failli crever ouais ouais c'est ça
faisait longtemps que j'étais pas passé
aussi proche de la mort
j'ai eu une chance incroyable
c'était vert pour les piétons donc je
vais pour traverser j'ai mon téléphone
comme ça devant et je vais pour appeler
Ludwig
et je vais pour appeler Ludwig
et je me dis NON je vais pas l'appeler
maintenant je l'appelle dans 3 minutes
je sais pas pourquoi je me dis ça je
regarde à droite je commence à traverser
et tout d'un coup je recommence à
regarder à droite et je vois la
conductrice donc qui est en train
d'arriver là je suis sur un passage
piéton et
et j'ai la priorité en fait enfin c'est
vert pour moi donc c'est rouge pour la
personne et je vois la conductrice qui
est en train de rouler peut-être à 30 40
km/h et qui est en train de regarder à
droite un truc et je sens la voiture qui
ferme pas qui qui freine pas je trace un
sprint pour arriver au bout la voiture
est passée à 40 km/h comme ça
ben je sais pas moi j'aurais pas couru
je me la prenais je crevais en fait
genre réellement premier degré
c'est incroyable mais genre vraiment
c'est j'étais à en fait je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai tourné la tête machin j'ai
fait attention j'ai vu là j'ai vu la
personne qui tournait la tête à droite
et là et la voiture qui freinait pas et
j'ai eu un coup de un coup de un coup de
panique enfin vraiment quoi j'ai
commencé à avoir le monde en slow motion
et j'ai tapé un sprint et la voiture
elle est vraiment vite
je sais pas si c'était 20 30 40 km heure
j'en sais rien mais je me la prenais je
courais pas je la prenais pleine face je
pense que je crevais
je pense premier degré que je crevais
mais genre rien enfin c'est un truc de
ouf
bah ouais ça a fout des quatre c'est une
enfilade terrible pour Yann
bon le match va quasiment être plié
bientôt à mon avis bon ça fait plaisir
bah je mets déjà trois hein
attention que Carlson juste perdre pas
d'intérêt pour le match qui en a
peut-être qui va peut-être rapidement
plus en avoir beaucoup il est nettement
plus fort un Magnus
mais c'est ouf je pense que j'étais
vraiment pas loin de c'est hyper
étonnant
mais je pense que si je regardais pas à
droite je me prenais la voiture c'est
100% et je pense qu'une voiture même à
30 km/h qui te qui te percute
après elle allait vraiment vite quand
même je pense 30 km/h ouais
quitte percute je pense que tu peux
mourir
30 40 km/h vous ne serez pas mort
dans chaque tête pas mort mais j'aurais
plus de jambes
elle allait quand même vite la voiture
ouais enfin si elle me percute je la la
vitesse à laquelle elle est 100% je
tombe ça hein
100% je tombais
ça c'est sûr c'est sûr que je restais
pas debout là c'est évidemment évident
c'était une petite Toyota ouais c'était
une petite caisse alors je sais pas si
c'était Toyota ou quoi mais c'était une
petite caisse
c'est complètement gagnant pour les
blancs il va gagner ça sans trop de
problèmes
c'est hyper facile à gagner
enfin j'ai vraiment eu du bol de
regarder quoi
parce que quand c'est vert pour les
piétons je regarde pas toujours
enfin je regarde toujours mais je suis
resté fixe sur la droite en fait
j'ai eu du bol de continuer à regarder
pendant que je traversais
et de voir que la personne regardait pas
du tout le passage piéton
elle s'arrête aussi non non elle a
continué non non mais enfin j'ai couru
et elle mais elle met juste passer genre
elle a juste assez sa route en fait
elle s'est rendu compte après parce que
quand elle après qu'elle soit passée
elle a freiné elle s'est excusée avec
avec la main elle s'est rendu compte
qu'elle a failli me tuer en fait
à contrecoup
la partie là vraiment pas d'intérêt il
gagne vraiment facilement Yann va
probablement abandonner ouais
ça fait bien 3 là la partie était finie
allez un petit gambiroit ça commence à
choque un peu côté Yann et ouais normal
quoi
normal aussi
on va pas en vouloir Ryan
c'est match sur Internet machin il a
envie de se faire kiffer avec un petit
Gambier quoi
il se rappelle plus là il essaie de se
rappeler
sachant que
Yann et un daficionado du Gamou
en tout cas construit qui est passé il y
a eu un petit j'ai eu un petit moment de
flottement après
ça fait une petite sensation bizarre
pendant quelques secondes
après tu as un genre de montée de stress
juste après je m'étais plus rendu compte
comment ça faisait
Marius
ouais c'est ça pendant le truc tu as pas
du tout peur tu vois le temps le moment
slow motion tu as l'impression que ton
cerveau il analyse genre hyper vite la
situation et que ça va que la le truc se
passe pas vite et après tu as un moment
c'est tu as un coup de stress
à posteriori
je sais pas trop comment ça s'explique
d'un point de vue chimique mais faisait
longtemps que se mettait plus arriver
ouais c'est la montée d'adrénaline et
puis après c'est quoi c'est la descente
du coup ça fait quoi en fait tu as
l'adrénie qui monte très vite ça c'est
sûr c'est le côté où ton instinct de
survie il est
il est hyper développé après du coup il
se passe quoi après le truc
voilà c'est vous voyez bien alors dit ça
se voit de toute façon elle menace
qu'elle prend des quatre Yann qui est
complètement foutu là on va voir s'il
réussit à arnaquer mais ça sent que ça
va pas
j'ai pris une voiture en traversant avec
mes sacs de course [__] moi je suis
pris un vélo une fois
ouais bon le match va perdre son intérêt
très rapidement comme comme Google
malheureusement
pitch et
speech Z
mais bon c'est toujours les joueurs qui
ont la vérité du
[Musique]
du match
pour avoir une Sophie Ruja qui s'est
quand même fini sur
sur victoire de saut quoi qu'il en soit
même si ça reste sympa à regarder non oh
mais c'est trop sympa regardez enfin
c'est
plus sympa à regarder mais
ouais malheureusement ça va perdre de
l'intérêt le niveau de jeu va baisser
l'intensité va baisser les parties
seront moins intéressantes
les pieds décarlnent
il avait perdu contre un VL
mais c'est dommage que Yann faisait un
bon début de match ça donne un petit
espoir mais il a perdu de l'intérêt trop
vite après il a joué hier pendant 4
heures ça c'était un gros problème
il y a pas cavalier 5 là
c'est le coup qu'elle pensait Magnus
aussi probablement car le 5 qui ferme
allez next
ça peut perdre l'intérêt côté Yann là
attention celle-là elle peut elle peut
faire mal j'ai la précédente c'est un
peu cadeau il y avait deux un
il avait une finale lui il la perd en
passe à deux il fait une gaffe on passe
à 3 2 là il fait une ouverture troll on
passe à 4 2 attention de ne pas perdre à
200% l'intérêt pour le match pour Yann
ça pourrait être long et ça pourrait
faire un score assez lourd à la sortie
du monde
il peut avoir tendance à craquer un peu
vite ouais
mais c'est compliqué ce format est très
difficile pour les joueurs moi
d'ailleurs j'ai refusé ils font ils font
un truc pour les gens qui sont pas grand
maître avec un format similaire j'ai
juste refusé de jouer en fait c'est
trop en fait
c'est trop
trop long ça rend en fait
c'est plus fort il est juste plus fort
il est incroyable en fait Magnus
ouais c'est c'est long et quand ça se
passe mal c'est
c'est pas amusant quoi
pour les joueurs le format 7 est
beaucoup plus drôle parce que
tu le perds pas mal aussi tu le perds
merci au revoir
là c'est vrai que quand tu commences à
perdre l'intérêt tu arrives plus trop à
te mettre dedans avec le format 7 tu
réussis un peu des fois à te dire allez
ok c'est le début du deuxième 7 let's go
en tout cas tu retrouves un peu
l'intérêt en début de cette au moins si
ça se passe mal
là faut vraiment que Yann sert la vie
maintenant
on va Magnus qui bâille aussi
attention de pas s'installer dans un
faux rythme pour ce match
l'avantage de ce format un contrario
c'est quand les matchs sont serrés tu es
vraiment sûr que c'est le meilleur qui
gagne quoi
quasiment quoique Sophie Ruja finalement
ça joue sur un armage et donc je sais
pas mais c'est des belles passes d'armes
d'un cadding c'était chaud une fois
ouais Naka Ding méritait de gagner
simplement vu les problèmes de connexion
etc c'est Naka qui avait gagné au
départage mais sur le contenu hors ça
évidemment Ding avait été plus fort ce
jour-là
moi sur le match fearuja sceaux
je suis absolument pas certain que le
plus fort est gagne personnellement
je suis absolument pas sûr que le
meilleur est gagné
est-ce que je commencerai à multer ouais
c'est pour ça que je garde de l'énergie
à pas trop calculé de variante
maintenant parce que je me répète mais 9
heures de commentaires d'affilée c'est
long
un peu long
donc on garde on garde l'énergie
échiquiere pour pas être complètement
dégoûté au moment du match de Maxime
surtout que là le match semble pas
spécialement intéressant
donc autant ne pas gaspiller toutes les
forces
il va être dur ça là pour gagner une
nouvelle fois
ouais bon il tient pour le moment Yann
faudrait au moins qu'il fasse nul et
qu'il en gagne une
je pense qu'à partir de plus 5 pour
Carlsen c'est quasi 100% donc faut qu'il
reste un peu coller quoi
une menace
[Musique]
pour des trois quand même
ça arrive c'est top 10 mondiale
dans quel monde Sarine est top 10
mondiale en fait
Sarine c'est plot hein
mondial je vais check ça mais pour moi
il est pas du tout mondial Sarine
feed
43e mondial il est même pas 27 feed 2689
en blitz donc non en Bliss non plus il
est pas top 10 mondial
top 3
ok c'est difficile de s'exprimer sur ses
joueurs
c'est très difficile de s'exprimer sur
ses joueurs
mais j'irai plutôt non mais en fait en
vrai j'en sais rien
on sait pas
on sait absolument pas on sait rien
quand on sait pas il vaut mieux se taire
pourquoi faire un format si long je
comprends pas l'intérêt alors non au
contraire c'est
en réalité c'est une philosophie du
speechasse c'est de vraiment la fin de
la compétition avoir le meilleur qui
gagne c'est l'intérêt du format très
long c'est pas très
télégénique ou spectateur friendly ça je
te le conseille mais ça a son charme
dans le sens où tu
où tu es vraiment bien sûr quoi
par comparativement au système 7 par
exemple ou
tu es quand même sûr mais un peu moins
quoi
là les matchs sont longs et tu peux pas
tu peux pas tu économiser un moment
donné ou quoi c'est vraiment le meilleur
le plus endurant c'est le meilleur
format pour un Nico par exemple
il y a le côté au bout de l'effort
exactement
c'est un format qui est vraiment calé
sur sur les qualités du carreau quoi
les gens te voient pas trop commenter
c'est pour ça
commentez quoi tu veux dire Elysium là
comme je disais le match actuel comme
j'en ai deux d'affilée
on regarde un peu les pauses et tout
mais on discute un petit peu on se
concentrera vraiment sur Maxime ou si le
match devient serré
mais oui non ouais voilà il se retourner
7 mais alors il a peut-être du bol que
soit pas grave fin du bol il a peut-être
bien joué là c'est pas du bol
s ça c'est cool ouais surtout dans son
optique de se qualifier pour les
candidats
ça peut faire la diff
ça va peut-être moins tenter de faire
des bullets en pleine nuit
juste les gens imaginent le match long
et ennuyant car ils ont l'habitude de te
voir à fond en commentaire ouais mais tu
peux pas être à fond déjà pendant 4h30
d'affilée élysé homme c'est pas humain
et puis en plus on a deux d'affilés donc
pendant 9 heures d'affilée c'est pas
humain
ça existe dans aucun sport même 4 heures
ça existe dans absolument rien en fait
face ça peut pas exister par
pas par principe mais par essence par
nature
il veut essayer de faire F5 et le matin
mais il va pas y arriver
ça me pue tu veux faire F5 et le matin
ça me fracasse bordel il va faire F5
c'est sûr
ça meule [__] ça fait rêver
[__]
que ça me pue
il fait G4 c'est le coup que j'avais
aussi en main G4 mais
c'était peut-être pas le coup de la
jauge
je donne égal alors que ça me paraît
hyper dur à jouer au noir
il veut défendre ça mais c'est peut-être
pas de bol ça il y a pas fou prendre 5
jolie il y avait tout regarde mais ouais
ça perd quand même
ah il y a pas de OK
ouais
jolie fois je suis
ok là il va perdre l'intérêt
là je pense c'est la partie trop elle
était jolie la finale de Magnus
ok il reste trois points d'écart je
pense à 5 points d'écart c'est 100 %
plié on va voir ce que nous dit le
machin de smarts là
oh la caméra sont mal cadrées là dessus
il donne que 85 % de chances à gagner de
Magnus ouais bon ok c'est range le truc
c'est quasi 100% des gens en réalité
ça va perdre l'intérêt là on voit un
Magnus très nonchalant après c'est un
peu son style
on espère un petit 6 2 quand même très
joli la partie précédente
ce format devient bien à partir de
demi-finales généralement ça dépend des
matchs
ça dépend des matchs
genre l'an dernier je crois que
les demi-finales étaient pas terrible la
finale non plus d'ailleurs et l'année
d'avant je crois que c'est l'inverse
c'était vraiment bien ça dépend vraiment
des années
tu es tributaire du scénario de match
il y a pas fou prendre des 5 là
une vraie chance contre Naka ce serait
IRL je te dirai oui là sur internet
ça va être très difficile le Bullet fait
mal en fait à la fin
ça riz aura zéro chance donc si c'est
une demi-finale Sarine Naka ça a aucun
intérêt ça
a vraiment un intérêt parce que bon de
notre côté mais
les choses de nvl sont assez réduites
sur Internet
et firou s'est fait éliminer
c'est genre 70 ans je pense ce serait
70-30 sans le Bullet je pense qu'avec le
Bullet c'est du 80/20 pour y carou 855
quoi je suis sur internet je change la
donne et je crois qu'il Caro il clique
vite
il joue plus sur internet que les autres
alors déjà il est très fort en plus il a
un peu c'est comme l'avantage du terrain
quoi je vois à domicile au foot
en bus Maxime et 55 ans il a pas
forcément de bons résultats contre un
cas en fait c'est pas un mauvais match
up pour Maxime
à la maison c'est comme jouer contre
Liverpool en film c'est ça
c'est exactement comme je Liverpool
Enfield
tu peux pas lutter
tu peux absolument pas lutter on verra
on verra bien ce que nous fait Maxime
ou c'est comme si tu joues contre mon oh
la photo
c'est vrai tu comprends quoi ok si c'est
mis tu as tes chances si c'est sur le
tas après tu sais que faut changer de
live en fait ça sert à rien
la laine est perdue
pigment là je dois voir ça ah c'est
assez
c'est assez fréquent je crois que le
dernier c'était mercredi
j'avais dominé le top contre qui ouais
mais j'étais un V9 sur la game mais
j'étais contre qui au top déjà
j'ai battu un perso qui me gêne
habituellement
c'est un yen
c'était un yen
qui s'est pris pas mal de h dans la
tronche
mais après le problème c'est que j'étais
vraiment en avait 9 et j'ai pas pu
carrer la game jusqu'au bout j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas un perso qui
peut vraiment charger jusqu'au bout
malheureusement ici pas très bien
mais ça va je suis un peu tout comme
comme tu m'as appris
je gère bien les je commence à bien
comprendre les timings pour mon niveau
attention je suis même pas classé encore
mais ça va je commence à savoir un peu
ce que je dois faire sur la map là c'est
un peu comme les échecs en fait ça
ressemble toujours être utile
voilà Yann il a un peu retrouvé
d'intérêt pour la partie c'est bien
mais je pense que le top c'est vraiment
mon poste c'est quoi c'est un poste de
solitaire
je progresse
surtout prends des cinq je sais pas si
il veut cavalier prend ou dame prend à 5
tu prends Rénac tu gagnes 20 minutes tu
prends la vie tu gagnes après 20 minutes
le truc c'est que je crois que Olaf
c'est vraiment ma philosophie ah c'est
bien joué FC il veut plus on prend puis
on prend qui est J6 il faut prendre des
5 dame prend
et là faut prendre des seins quand même
et donc c'est Dame prend B1
dame prend B1 tu reprends des 5 dans 7
tu reprends à 5 d'un Français 6 et le
rat noir est trop faible probablement
j'imagine c'est ça la ligne
vous dame G4 ouais bon c'est celle là
celle que j'avais aussi mais là c'est
peut-être tu comprends
et dame prend tu reprends à 5
mais il cavalier arrive sur F5 ça va
gagner pour les blancs
si peu counta cavalier H4 cavalier F5
et vu la jauge il doit pas pouvoir
donc c'est que c'était tout raciste
probablement dame prend et tout reprend
F6
menace cavalier F3 quand même
portant
F6
bah il est complètement fermé parce
qu'il avait pas qu'il y a des sets à
cause de dame F5
dame prend des cinq doux à gagner parce
que sur retour des systèmes
ok ça doit gagner tranquille on va voir
comment ça se termine roi G8 cavalier 5
cavalier H6
il y a plus de
ok bon ça peut redonner un peu d'intérêt
au match
que c'est une plutôt bonne partie de
Yann
et alors là c'est Magnus ouais ouais il
a souvent l'air blasé quand il joue
quand même
il a souvent l'air d'être un peu un peu
blasé
de la française
est-ce qu'on sait quand Maxime joue
contre niallois à 19h c'est pour ça
qu'on garde notre énergie là pour le
pour le match qui nous intéresse nous le
plus évidemment le match de mvl
ça va être je trouve que vous
mial il est pas ouais moi je trouve pas
ouf
moi je trouve pas ouf après
il peut complètement écraser Maxime
c'est possible mais franchement
sur Internet c'est fort quand même ouais
moi je quand je juge un truc je prends
pas en compte les niveaux sur internet
en fait
ça m'intéresse juste pas en fait
donc non on y va intrinsèque maxime est
nettement plus fort après
mais sur Internet ouais mais en fait là
dans ces cas-là je peux pas prendre en
compte internet parce que moi aussi je
peux je peux je peux tarte et Maxime si
j'ai envie tu peux lui mettre Deezer un
maximum enfin j'ai au bout d'un moment
je peux pas dans mon analyse du match
penser à Internet enfin sinon tu fais
plus aucun pronostic de rien
Maxime et nettement plus fort que Niall
Sarine genre c'est incomparable
après tout peut arriver mais bon
j'ai pas
c'est un peu mieux pour les blancs quand
même avec le foot casse blanche
il veut refaire rejouer une finale
contre Yann
Carson Naka qui gagnera on est obligé de
mettre NACA favoris de la compétition je
crois qu'il a gagné 3 ou 4 fois
consécutives là il bat tout le monde
tout le temps
donc pour moi
j'aimerais que tu fasses un route j'aime
KF ce serait kiffant et je peux pas j'ai
pas le niveau en fait je peux pas y
arriver
trop vieux et
puis surtout une petite fille maintenant
donc trop dure malheureusement je ne
pourrai pas répondre
positivement à ta requête
tu aurais l'argent le niveau en calcul
pour être j'aime
plus maintenant je calcule pas vite
je suis relativement lent
illes
j'ai plus le niveau les amis il faut le
reconnaître
tu es devenu vieux et lent
surtout vieux en fait c'est ça qui est
terrible
je suis plus vieux que lent en fait
je sais pas si je suis plus vieux ou
lent
tu fais un des tactiques que j'ai quand
même fatigué
qui sont encore plus vieux et plus
longue que moi
bah qu'il est pas tout neuf non plus
ouais mais il était top 10 mondiale bah
qui peut pas comparer
par rapport à son niveau prime il est
aussi vieux et lent
on est vieux on est là ce que vous
voulez
il faut accepter
on
même pas 40 ans ça va
pour n'importe quel sport de haut niveau
ou n'importe quel
activité compétitive
37 ans c'est beaucoup
intéressant la partie ça reste toujours
aux alentours des galles même si la
jauge de l'avantage noir à mon avis ça
tient bien pour Magnus mais il abuse un
peu
ce que tu penses que n'est pas une
chance ou 0 ça dépend plus de Magnus que
de dépôt d'après moi
je vais vous dire je comprends pas
pourquoi c'est mieux pour les Noirs mais
oui la jauge est revenu à égal il devait
y avoir un truc
c'est un peu mieux pour les blancs quand
même
des pions sont sur la bonne couleur
je check comme ça Carona va taper les
2850 en longueur il était très fort
il veut peut-être aussi 3 5 c'est pour
ça qu'il fait cavalier 4 pour avoir
ouais ça va tenir le roi rentre pas
si le roi arrivait en E5 je pense ça
aurait pu être chiant pour pour Yann
la plus vieille personne à être assez
grande c'est horrible Chabana face à 66
ans ouais mais tu as beaucoup de
personnes Union soviétique qui pouvaient
pas avoir le titre et qui l'ont eu tard
pour plein de raisons mais c'est
il est pas vraiment devenu grand maître
à 66 ans en fait je sais pas trop
comment dire
la plupart des Soviétiques que vous
voyez être devenus grand maître tard
c'est parce que
ils ont pas forcément eu le droit de
jouer des tournois qui leur permettaient
de l'être plutôt
je crois que c'est la pause
alors on se retrouve dans une dizaine de
minutes à tout de suite les amis
vous voulez streamer des échecs comme
vos créateurs préférés tels que
blindstream Naka ou les soeurs
le programme de Community streamer de
cheese.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimentés
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience vous connectant
votre compte à cheese.com et profiter de
la visibilité offerte alors d'autres
plateforme de jeu il vous suffit de
relier votre compte à
cheese.com/settings/connecting
mettre échec comme catégorie sur twitch
et commencer à streamer
d'une expérience sans publicité sur
chaise.com et apparaître et dans notre
liste de streamers en direct votre
profites.com affichera votre stream
twitch vous sera aussi mis en avant
durant vos parties offert utiliser la
commande community streamer dans le chat
faites grossir votre audience sans plus
attendre
[Musique]
les amis je suis matrixé par la pub
je suis complètement matrixé par la pub
fiascom je suis de nouveau sur la game
clash royale je suis complètement
matrixé par la pub c'est terrible au
lieu de me reposer
j'ai pu m'ont fait très très mal
je suis fort
un homme matrixé par par la publicité
c'est dur
le match repart
je me fais détruire là je me fais
détruire
mais ça peut sortir Magnus en 2000 ça
dépend de l'intérêt de Magnus pour la
compétition si l'envie de gagner il
gagnera
avec cavalue aussi ça marrant je finis
ma gueule mais désolé là c'est comme qui
me qui me fait très très mal niveau
publicitaire
ils font extrêmement mal chasse comme
on va voir ainsi Magnus réussi à gagner
ils m'ont mis dans une boucle c'est
terrible
c'est infernal
c'est trop
en plus j'ai le seum parce que je perds
c'est terrible
bon sortie de la boucle de chaise comme
c'est quoi
ça va plutôt bien pour Magnus hein pour
les noirs
j'ai l'impression que c'est bien pour
les Noirs je comprends pas pourquoi la
jauge s'affole pas il y a dame c'est
encore
pas ce qu'il a sur cavalier des deux en
fait
je pense c'est pour ça qu'il grimace
il se passe c'est quoi sur
curiosité
ah il y avait ces cinq intermédiaires
c'est pour ça que je fais dame c'est 5
j'ai du mal à j'ai du mal à me
concentrer je suis vraiment désolé
j'ai du mal à me concentrer attendez on
a
ok donc ça rentre dans cette finale
[Musique]
ouais bon ça va être Dame des deux
garde tes forces ouais en vrai je me
rends compte que même en étant comme ça
j'en utilise quand même c'est long ça
fait déjà ça fait déjà deux heures de
match avec la avec la régie tous fait
déjà deux heures et demie je me rends
compte que les
même si j'économise mes forces
ça va être dur d'être chaud pour le
match de Maxime Keny Adam des deux qui
est marrant sur dame et Adam et un roi
H2 dame prend G3 puis on prend F6
je pense qu'il va faire dame D1 je
pensais qu'il allait faire dame dernier
changer les dames
quand j'aurai du temps là tu vois le
problème c'est que
j'ai trop de choses à faire trop de
Tournes en commentaire en fait
et mine de rien ça m'enlève de la force
et puis ça m'enlève de l'envie de faire
des échecs aussi
donc quand j'aurai envie enfin
j'ai envie de base mais je suis trop
fatigué
pour bien jouer j'ai pas envie de mal
jouer
et j'ai envie d'avoir quelques jours
devant moi pour me remettre en forme
quand j'aurai donc quand j'aurai du
temps
mais c'est pas d'actualité là j'aurais
aimé faire en septembre mais comme tu
vois Coupe du Monde et puis là on
réenchaîne avec plein d'endettement
j'avais pas prévu de base qui est autant
de speechers en aussi peu de temps mais
bon ce délecte évidemment c'est tant
mieux tant mieux qui est autant de
compétitions c'est cool ça permet de
voir les joueurs de haut niveau
s'affronter donc ça c'est vraiment
génial mais après voilà on est en
patient un petit peu sur le côté envie
de faire des échecs à côté quoi
bah après hier j'ai un peu rejouer en
avec l'événement qui était marrant là
roi de la colline c'était cool ça change
un petit peu c'était marrant c'était
sympa j'ai bien kiffé perso
tu reprends B3 il veut quoi j'ai pas la
rêve c'est 5 P5
[Musique]
c'est nul ce truc
est-ce que tu comptes suivre la Coupe
d'Europe des Clubs ou pas pas du tout
mais il y a pas de temps je crois à
cause de tomber 7
ça c'est nul allez c'est bien il tient
il y a
encore une tempête on personne ne
connaît tu parles de la Coupe d'Europe
des Clubs ouais c'est c'est encore une
compétition en fait il y en a des
compétitions d'échec c'est incroyable on
parlait avec un pote à tout à l'heure
j'ai jamais vu un sport où il y avait
autant de compétences je crois vraiment
que c'est un truc de ouf
c'est incroyable en fait
il y a énormément de compètes et très
peu de compètes avec un réel enjeu c'est
très paradoxal
je pense que c'est dû au fait que les
compètes d'échecs sont très longs à
chaque fois
c'est pas vraiment qui en a beaucoup
mais c'est que chaque compète dure très
longtemps
et donc ça donne un peu cet effet après
encore une compète
donc c'est ça qui donne cet effet un peu
aux échecs il y a tout le temps quelque
chose et au final encore une compète
en fait tu préférerais quasiment rien
qu'une compète à force parce que il y en
a il y en a beaucoup mais comme je
disais je pensais pas lié à la quantité
mais c'est plus lié à la longévité
mais c'est comme Magnus contre prendre
son titre champion du monde
[Musique]
pas actuellement non
mais il changera peut-être d'avis
il changera peut-être d'avis
il y a plusieurs formats aussi donc plus
de compètes logiquement pas forcément
plus de formats il y a au tennis aussi à
beaucoup de formats
gagnants
de cette gagnante 3 7 gagnants il y a
toutes les surfaces
je pense c'est plus parce que les toutes
les compétitions d'échecs sont très
longues
il devient quoi
la situation un peu particulière avec
lui dans le sens où
il a dit à l'issue du match championnat
du monde qu'il aura arrêté les échecs
s'il avait perdu je pense qu'il en a
globalement marre de jouer et là il
continue de jouer aux échecs que parce
qu'il est champion du monde et à mon
avis ça est fin de ce qu'on en comprend
de ces interviews
et donc en quelque sorte ça explique
le pourquoi du comment quoi
toujours des compètes ouais dans le foot
il y a trop de compétition le rugby non
ça va
c'est bien équilibré
dans une saison tu as ton championnat
national la Coupe d'Europe et les
compétitions internationales il y a plus
ou moins toujours de l'ail si tu suis
une équipe en fait tu suis pas
énormément de match un match ça dure 90
minutes
en tout cas c'est mille fois moins long
que les échecs là c'est gagné à cavalier
dame 7 et qui prend F7 d'un prime
et puis tous les matchs on leur a en jeu
etc aux échecs tu sais pas trop pourquoi
ça joue
et le match d'hier soir moi j'ai pas vu
les commentaires drivenzy parce que je
pouvais pas mettre et la télé comme j'ai
qu'un écran je vais mettre la télé et le
stream mais
match d'hier j'ai été fou devant la télé
j'étais juste fou devant la télé
Carlson tu en penses quoi je suis pas
d'accord
je suis pas d'accord je sais pas comment
Hikaru peut s'auto proclamer numéro 1 ou
numéro 2 mondial Ambit alors qu'il a
jamais gagné un championnat du monde
ça c'est un misclique de la part de
Carlson mais il y en a pas profité il
avait promouvoir cavalier C3
les commentaires TF1 étaient nuls c'est
devenu tellement habituel
malheureusement
ouais j'ai l'impression que les les
commentaires télé grand public
devait deviennent neuneu mais
ça suit la mode
de ce qu'on voit qui se fait de plus en
plus sur Youtube et en fait dès qu'on
veut faire du grand public
faut toujours
enfin c'est devenu insupportable en fait
cette nouvelle manière de faire mais
j'ai l'impression que pour tout le
contenu grand public que ce soit télé
YouTube ou quoi faut toujours un truc
hyper aseptisé tout le temps ultra
positif
c'était
horrible c'était horrible
tu as l'impression que c'est tu es
toujours en danse dans cette pseudo
bienveillance machin et tout c'est
insupportable
ils ont dit qu'ils ont pas bien joué sur
TF1 quand même mais c'est pas pas bien
joué ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est horrible ce qu'ils ont fait hier
Coupe du monde en France à domicile on
attend ça depuis longtemps et tu fais
une bouillie de rugby comme ça
contre du ruguay sans passer sur les
parler fondamentaux c'est cataclysmique
ce qu'ils ont fait hier
ça a gagné ou quoi mais tu peux pas
peux pas être là en mode on va quand
même prendre le bonus au Francis machin
ou quoi non enfin c'est horrible ce
qu'ils ont fait après c'est l'équipe est
mais c'est pas arrêté d'avoir des
excuses c'est l'équipe B et eux c'est
ça allait pas du tout ce qu'ils ont fait
hier ils ont pris le match à l'envers
il y a rien qui allait on a même
quasiment de la chance de gagner
non mais l'Uruguay une belle équipe on
doit leur mettre 60 hier
bon là la partie c'est incroyable si une
époque gagne pas après un tel misclick
mais il est peut-être en train de faire
n'importe son cavalier à 4 complètement
bloqué
non mais la charnière hier c'était
c'était mou ça ça sortait pas rapidement
le ballon des rock mais
moi ce que je comprends pas c'est
surtout devant
c'est surtout devant que je comprends
pas comment à aucun moment on met de
l'impact devant comment est-ce qu'il y a
aucun moment dans le match où on les
prend au cœur
il y a personne qui était capable
d'avancer dans cette équipe c'était
incroyable
mais c'est un peu dans sur la lignée de
ce qu'on a fait en première mi-temps
contre les All Blacks j'ai l'impression
que tu as tout le monde qui l'oublie
mais la première mi-temps contre les
Blacks ils nous mettent 20 points il
mène de 20 points c'est normal ils ont
eu tous les ballons ils avaient tout
movaca fait du bien ouais
c'est pas vilain normalement son rôle
non mais bon tu as l'impression que si
tu as plus Jonathan anti au centre il y
a personne qui avance
non mais bon et puis bon en face c'était
c'est tes niveaux pro des deux quoi
mais il y a aucun moment ou un moment
donné tu as un avant je sais pas moi le
8 c'était je long ou même tu as aussi
fait noir ou quoi qui prend le ballon ou
même un pilier j'en sais rien moi mais
qui prend il y a pas faux écart là ah il
veut
quatre dames prend le 4 quoi c'est chaud
qui prend le ballon et qui avance dans
l'axe en fait
il y avait une affûte à la France pour
la France à la mi-temps ouais mais il y
avait 9 8 mais franchement sur le
contenu du match il y aurait eu 25 à 8
on n'aurait pas
on aurait rien dit à vous écouter on a
perdu notre premier match mais on n'a
pas perdu notre premier match on fait
deux mauvais match d'entrée après
peut-être que on sera plus près
physiquement à partir des quarts de
finale mais il faut arrêter de faire les
bisounours on fait des mauvais matchs on
fait des mauvais matchs
là on joue mal c'est tout
hier on est dominé quand même dans le
jeu par l'Uruguay quoi
donc les blagues c'est pas un mauvais
match c'était pas dit que c'était un
mauvais match mais la première mi-temps
elle est mauvaise
la deuxième mi-temps était très bonne
mais en fait si on tourne à 15 points de
retard c'est pas sûr qu'on remonte
pour le moment on n'est pas bon
franchement c'est le carton de taf il
fait nuit à héros je suis même pas sûr
qu'on gagne alors pour moi il est rouge
il y a le coude qui part directement à
la tête le joueur il a un peu en train
de tomber mais il est déjà un peu bas
au moment où tu as aussi fini a
enclenche son son placage enfin si on
peut appeler c'est un plaquage et
au-delà de ça le coup il va pleine tête
c'est-à-dire que même si les 10 cm plus
haut elle lui arrive en pleine tronche
donc pour moi l'arbitre a été assez
gentil en mettant qu'un jeu après bon
c'est pas scandaleux carton jaune non
plus mais cordes carton rouge aurait
jamais on n'aurait pas été scandaleux
et histoire de circonstances atténuantes
tu as quand même le coup de qui lui
arrive en pleine tronche
enfin tu peux mettre rouge tu peux
mettre jaune mais ça ça a l'appréciation
de l'arbitre mais genre ni l'un ni
l'autre n'était scandaleux quoi
mais bon hier ouais arrêtez de dire
équipe B qui B qui bait bon ça gagne
quand même pour pour Yann après la
partie après le mystique avait perdu en
intérêt
rugby a pas vraiment d'équipe B puisque
les joueurs que tu vois c'est des
joueurs qui vont rentrer en cours de
match et vous rendez pas compte que
l'Uruguay c'est comme si mvl fait un
match de speechers contre moi et
qu'après trois heures de jeu mvl hymen
j'en sais rien moi dis ça 8 quoi
on se poserait quand même des questions
sur mvl c'est réellement la différence
de niveau hier entre fin
la différence supposée de niveau entre
l'Uruguay et la France c'est la
différence de niveau entre mvl et moi
quoi si vous vous rendez pas compte en
fait
c'est un semi-pro quand on peut dire
ouais bon à force de glisser je suis
semi-pro en blitz contre un top mondial
mais je suis censé me faire déglinguer
c'est c'est
incroyable en fait bon c'est un mauvais
match ça veut rien dire on avait bien
perdu contre les tangas avant d'aller en
finale donc tout est possible
on a pris le match à l'envers etc là il
va avoir tout à deux tours des deux
c'est assez joli comme plan
il y a 4 ans ça joue vraiment mieux que
Namibie
le chat
à un moment donné le sport de haut
niveau c'est tu te regardes dans une
glace c'est pareil aux échecs hein t'es
pas là tu as à te touche Fin comprenez
que au niveau c'est une exigence quoi tu
peux pas quand tu es sportive de haut
niveau quand tu as une équipe de haut
niveau te satisfaire du match d'hier
soir et c'est pareil aux échecs vu qu'on
parle d'échec aussi en même temps on ne
peut pas quand on veut faire du haut
niveau se contenter de la médiocrité en
fait vous n'arrivez pas à le comprendre
ça un sportif de haut niveau ne peut pas
se contenter de la médiocrité hier ça a
gagné mais c'était médiocre
les joueurs n'étaient pas satisfaits il
y a quelque chose qui allait pas ils
vont se remettre en question ils vont
revenir plus fort c'est pas le
Niger c'est dans le sport de haut niveau
tu la médiocrité tu ne peux pas tu ne
peux pas t'en contenter c'est c'est
autre chose
donc évidemment ils vont se remettre en
question et ils vont ils vont envoyer du
jeu mais c'est moi je parlais juste des
commentateurs de TF1 qui à un moment
donné tu es obligé de dire que c'était
médiocre hier
tu veux pas me parler machin ils sont
valeureux ils sont nananie ils sont
hyper forts non ils sont nuls et on est
nuls c'est tout
on n'a pas on n'a pas mis en place les
fondamentaux on les a on les a pas pris
devant on n'a pas fait ce qu'il fallait
et voilà il arrivait ce qu'il arrivait
on gagne quand même par la petite porte
et tant mieux
mais ils ont dit que c'était pas bon
mais ils ont pas dit que c'était pas bon
à la moindre réaction ils sont là machin
mais quatrième essai magnifique le bonus
offensif
heureusement bonus offensif on le prend
même pas mais heureusement bonus
offensif excusez-moi
tu peux pas être là ma sœur la France
extraordinaire prend le bonus offensif
contre l'Uruguay non mais un moment
donné
il faut se respecter soi-même et
respecter les autres
bonus offensif ça doit pas être une
question dans un match comme ça
on prend pas un ballon en touche on fait
pas un mot les mêlés bon leur arbitrer
il a été un peu sympa avec eux à mon
avis mais on en perd quand même
quelques-unes enfin bon il y a rien qui
allait
on gagne même pas le ping-pong rugby non
mais bon c'est heureusement qu'on est
laissé sur sur leur dégagement avec
heureusement que movaca est rentré
d'ailleurs on a pas movaka hier je suis
même pas sûr qu'on gagne le match
on l'a pris j'ai sur papier pourquoi
on n'a pas pris le bonus offensif hier
c'est 4 essais
l'arbitre nous la volé non mais bon
arrêtez de parler de l'arbitrage tous
vous regardez dommage de rugby par an
vous me parlez de l'arbitrage c'est plus
pourquoi il était pas le il était pas le
troisième essai mais c'était
complètement justifié le quatrième
je rappelle plus ce qui avait le je me
rappelle même plus tellement le match
mycoeur je me rappelle même plus
d'arbitrage était très bon mais bon
mais bon c'est bien ce que je dis c'est
que maintenant quand tu es sur les trucs
de grande écoute tu as plus de
commentaires pour pour les passionnés
ah c'est le fameux rock avec Makalu
ouais non il y a pas essai
il peut traverser au pied mais fallait
que ce soit un autre joueur qui prenne
le ballon elle l'avait il avait il y a
pas il y a pas essayé
bon ça va gagner pour Carlsen le match
va suivre un faux rythme un petit peu
comme ça j'ai l'impression
Magnus qui reste à deux trois points
d'avance
je pense pas qu'il suit pour gagner du
tout
sachant que ce serait fini qu'il y aura
un cavalier au 7 mais non alors c'est
pas terminé la partie reprend des 8 il
faut prendre H7
la finale doit gagner
dans un arbitre qui a abusé c'était
Fidji Pays de Galles
en fait moi j'ai une autre théorie sur
la Coupe du monde
moi ma théorie c'est que la préparation
physique optimale elle va arriver avec
le match contre l'Italie
et que et qu'ils ont fait le calcul que
les Blacks feraient pareil qui sera un
peu en décalé et que de toute façon vous
pouvez perdre le match contre les Blacks
parce qu'on a que des matchs faciles
derrière et que notre équipe elle va
arriver en pleine carburation à partir
de début octobre moi c'est ça ma théorie
et c'est pour ça qu'on fait des matchs
pour ave pour le moment et qu'on n'a pas
été physiquement on n'était pas super
bon contre les Blacks
hier c'était catastrophique
mais je pense que c'est parce qu'on a
une préparation et qu'on profite de
notre groupe extrêmement facile pour
pour monter en puissance et être
vraiment un autre pic pour les cartes de
mie et final
moi c'est ça ma théorie
quand l'Italie c'est chaud non en Italie
c'est des plots on va les défoncer
et tu peux pas tenir un pic de forme de
deux mois et donc c'est pour ça que
Galtier hier il était pas catastrophe
parce que il sait très bien que
on est taillé pour être fort à partir
des cars
donc voilà mon analyse personnelle
ça n'empêche car ils ont pas mis les
choses à l'endroit pour pour battre les
Uruguayens
italiens rugby c'est un peu comme la
Belgique au foot ils ont la position ils
ont du mal à concrétiser tu es dur quand
même avec Kita du rugby
et je pense que c'est une des raisons
pour laquelle l'Irlande galère tout le
temps Coupe du Monde c'est que l'Irlande
ils sont une nouvelle fois ils sont très
bon dès le début et je pense qu'ils sont
très bons trop tôt
l'Irlande
après moi mon rêve demain c'est une
victoire du Portugal contre le pays de
Galles mais
très improbable
il prend le 4 là il veut un truc avec
Dame G4 ou dame F3 mais je sais pas si
ça passe
impossible qu'il perde contre le
Portugal qu'est-ce que j'aimerais une
victoire du Portugal
je crois qu'il y a une ligne un peu
marrante ça ça
ça
et ça
marron comme ligne
on a pris cette partie
c'est la même idée
il va faire dame G5 échanger les dames
le truc c'est que le match est compliqué
parce que Magnus mène on voit pas
comment Yann peut revenir au score
trop en dessous dans le jeu donc le
match en fait il suit lentement mais
sûrement sa vie
de match quoi
il va y avoir des beaux matchs aussi
d'équipe de seconde zone
il va y avoir quelques petits matchs
sympas genre Georgie Fidji ça peut être
sympa
genre ils ont perdu contre le pays de
Galles donc ils vont suer
Italie ça peut être sympa ouais qui sait
ce que j'ai des places non j'ai pas
réussi à avoir de place
assez contre l'Australie qu'ils ont
perdu les Géorgiens ouais c'est pas le
c'est pas le Pays de Galles ouais désolé
mais ils peuvent battre le Pays de
Galles genre
mais il a plus trois secondes c'est pour
ça que ça passe pas son truc
il va devoir faire nul
la dernière fois
et il tombe soit la catacée ce match
Yann qui comprend pas non plus
il a quand même perdu ça la Magnus ah
ouais le match est ouais c'est parti
hier
qu'est-ce qu'ils font
il a oublié le temps en fait
ah le match est vraiment dans un faux
rythme
bon allez petite pause et on revient
donc c'est si suite
à tout de suite les amis
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyses avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts
et même vos personnalités préférées du
monde des échecs et les emojis
disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
coûts spéciales restent sur les
chéquiers jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit
effacées pour ce faire il suffit de
cliquer avec le bouton gauche de la
souris sur l'emoji ou de cliquer sur le
bouton Tout effacer
[Musique]
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
bon ça va reprendre après ça te dit à
face incroyable de Magnus
un joli mystique qui nous a amené sur
sur des trucs qu'on devait pas voir
donc 26 minutes encore dans ce 3 + 1
Magnus qui réussit pas à rester assez
concentré pour faire les cars
mais je pense que il a il a beaucoup de
marge
mais il retourne dans cette finale
on va voir ce que ça va donner
qu'à la position est correcte
pour Yann mais bon Magnus
veut essayer de le mettre à mal en
finale
c'est normal c'est son point fort
en tout cas c'est une énième finale on
va voir si réussi à la gagner
bon c'est position
égale pour l'ordinateur mais plus
agréable à jouer pour pour les blancs
quoi en gros
comme ça c'est simple à comprendre
bon il pousse les pions au centre on va
voir ce que ça donne
ouais c'est égal mais mon plus agréable
à jouer enfin je sais pas c'est plus
agréable pour les blancs c'est juste
Magnus qui qui a envie d'avoir ses
positions là
donc elle voit un serveur est plus ou
moins dur qu'une partie de cadence lente
qui peut durer 5 6 7 heures
ah c'est plus fort j'en sais rien c'est
équivalent les deux sont durs et
pénibles
mais c'est quand même éprouvant
d'enchaîner les parties après c'est un
peu plus amusant mais bon
surtout à haut niveau comme ça tu peux
pas
tu peux pas déconcentrer mais c'est plus
marrant quand même
à jouer
mais là ouais la grosse erreur dans la
partie précédente peut faire mal
bon il a rien obtenu
il va son bras qui va s'endormir ouais
mais il est un peu statue nonchalante
généralement Carlsen quand même
mais après genre l'an dernier on se
pitcher il avait vraiment pas très bien
joué contre Rica dans Final
si ils ont le droit de proposer nul oui
bon de toute façon le match nous
intéresse vraiment c'est le suivant
regardez l'espace ouais Magnus des fois
tu as l'impression que ça le saoule de
jouer tu sais pas pourquoi
que ça le saoule ouais possible
après je sais pas pourquoi ça le saoule
mais peut-être ça le saoule
va réussir une nouvelle fois par un tour
de magie à prendre l'avantage c'est fou
il est vraiment fort il va marquer F3
peut-être
et des quatre tours ah c'est terrible il
a tellement de marge en fait
ouais nettoie
ouais ça manque un peu de challenge je
sais pas trop
après faut dire on n'est pas forcément
aidé dans les échecs par notre
calendrier quoi
tu as du mal à te motiver parce que
tu vois je sais pas au tennis tu prends
un Djoko il a tout gagné mais tu gagnes
des énième Grand Chelem je sais pas tu
as toujours de l'intérêt là aux échecs
en fait tu gagnes des trucs
mais on s'en fout un peu je sais pas
trop comment dire t'as pas à ce côté
historique des tournois tu as pas c'est
difficile pour les joueurs
tu as un peu tout gagné plus tu as pas
de public aussi je dois dire dans les
autres sports genre si on reprend le
tennis je sais pas tu as l'impression de
faire vibrer le public et tout il se
passe quand même un truc quand tu joues
sur le court central etc là aux échecs
tu vois là il est tout seul dans sa
chambre
je trouve que c'est plus dur quand tu as
tout gagné de garder la motivation aux
échecs
je trouve je trouve que c'est plus
compliqué aux échecs
le savant
un Wimbledon ça aucune histoire tout le
monde s'en fiche de qui gagne
en vérité il y a pas de public il y a
pas de tu vois il y a pas ce côté
compliqué le niveau des échecs qui est
vraiment
manque de hype manque d'engouement
c'est difficile pour les joueurs je
comprends tout à fait
ça fait mal au cœur pour Yann ouais mais
Yann il est un peu moins fort c'est
normal qui perd il a plutôt je trouve
qu'ils se défend plutôt bien après
c'est vraiment fort
il y a pas de célébration des joueurs
aussi ouais ouais il y a pas de
c'est très solitaire
je crois qu'il veut des cas je pense
c'est sûr que peu importe le nombre de
grands thèmes quand tu as un pays qui se
lève pour toi ça fait quelque chose
c'est ça alors qu'aux échecs tu peux
gagner ce que tu veux
tout le monde s'en fout
tiens même à League of Legends quand tu
regardes les finales là qui a eu des à
Montpellier même si tu gagnes
ton troisième quatrième championnat
d'affilée en trois quatre ans ce qu'a
fait la cacord j'ai plus exactement les
les chiffres mais quand tu vois 10000
personnes comme ça qui qui viennent te
supporter et qui
et qui sont là dans la salle à
t'encourager à machin et à vibrer avec
toi pour pour ta victoire et évidemment
ça donne envie quoi
même si de base tu es un peu blasé du
truc ça te ok les gens ils sont venus et
tout
tu as l'impression de faire quelque
chose leurs échecs c'est vrai que tu as
pas cette impression et peut-être que
c'est ça qui donne cet air un petit peu
Blaze à Magnus aussi quoi là je crois
qu'il y a assez prends des cartes qui
est très fort
c'est un peu fade quoi
faire l'écart ça fait un moment qu'il
doit le faire il fait trop de cadeaux il
va arrêter là
il y a foi j'avais depuis le début
cavalier 3 puis on prend des quatre raté
par Magnus
lol c'est beaucoup du fait historique
des castors
pas que Phi building
les castors si tu leur donnes leur donne
la même action qu'aux échecs ils veulent
ils vont pas faire grand-chose
moi j'ai un peu essayé mais au bout d'un
moment tu peux pas faire grand-chose
pas besoin de contenu
tu as besoin de contenu
si le contenu suit pas en fait tu es
pris au piège
il y a tout un tas de trucs qui sont
fait
sur LoL notamment il se passe des choses
en fait moi-même je suis la scène
eSport de là et je suis plus
et les échecs c'est jamais quoi
t'es pas dans des conditions où tu peux
être
les meilleurs commentaires en termes de
rimes ça reste champion du monde de
Blitz ouais mais le poulet bas du truc
c'est que même si tu fais des super
commentaires
c'est difficile quand il y a zéro et
dans la salle et que quand quelqu'un est
champion du monde il se passe rien quoi
visuellement
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire mec est
champion du monde il y a un quelqu'un
qui vient lui serrer la main et c'est
fin du casque quoi
c'est un peu un peu particulier là ça va
gagner un tour B2 il y a X3 il y a B2
bien joué Magnus
en fait tu vois même sur une bac up où
on a un peu de mal à commenter parce que
il y a quelques petits problèmes
techniques pour bien commenter sur place
on réussit à générer plus de hype
alors c'est fini
parce que tu as le public parce qu'il se
passe quelque chose
on n'est pas des pics d'audience sur des
événements et ce qui est important alors
si
mais ça génère pas de hype sur le moyen
terme
et ouais c'est un peu c'est un peu ça le
truc
et les joueurs voient la cam de
l'adversaire aussi ouais
bon la Magnus a vraiment fait les cars 4
points normalement c'est plié
si il fait pas n'importe quoi et qui
perd pas son intérêt pour le match
peut-être le temps rappelle-toi il y a
pas si longtemps personne ne s'intéresse
aux échecs et aujourd'hui tout le monde
s'y mis c'est plutôt l'inverse la
céramique de ce qu'on voit sur les
tournois c'est au contraire les gens se
désintéressent petit à petit là
maintenant aux échecs
mais je veux dire aux compétitions mais
c'est normal
on peut pas en vouloir aux gens
contre Maxime il aurait du mal aussi
mais contre Wesley ce sera pas
complètement gagné d'avance
je pense que c'est les trois seuls
joueurs qui peuvent battre Magnus
d'ailleurs Hikaru et même favoris mais
c'est Maxime
Wesley
et
aussi ouais pour le gêner
mais Yann c'est pas le profil en fait
Magnus il a trop la main mise sur lui
enfin bon faudra déjà qu'il puisse
battre un joueur correct en speechers
pour le moment il a galéré contre André
King et il a perdu contre Wesley donc
c'est un peu
tôt pour le voir Batman
mais théoriquement possible
ouais trop marqué offert rouge Yann pour
que le match puisse représenter
quelqu'un
et même là je trouve que Yann fait un
très bon match honnêtement je suis même
plutôt surpris de la performance de Yann
et il est quand même 4 points derrière
et Magnus a fait un gros cadeau
tu pars trop dans ton délire de trashtag
ce dernier temps c'est mieux quand tu es
respectueux franchement en même temps tu
es pas en train de jouer
je sais pas de quoi tu parles un frérot
juste en train de regarder le match je
sais pas où tu vois du trashtalk
c'est terrible ça
mais malheureusement
malheureusement match ouais c'est un peu
comme le match qu'on a vu avec du cash
de Bakis ça a jamais
expliqué ça ça demande vraiment vos
matchs on enverra peut-être cette année
on espère
aller en train de le fermer belle bonne
partie de Magnus
si gagne celle-là ça termine ça ferme
mais bon ça reste relou à tenir le
cavalier est plus fort que
coup d'ordi mais hyper fort
Magnus qui est un peu fait non là il se
retrouve avec beaucoup de pions sur noir
marrant
c'est parti logique non elles sont assez
logiques leur partie en fait c'est juste
que ça
trop d'écart
je vais devoir chercher moi-même car
au-delà de la Kaya ça joue pour les
points non ça joue que pour la caillasse
là il y a vraiment que la caillasse
C8 3 prend le 3
dans les traits des jeux vidéo même très
populaire comme Super Smash a des gros
événements mais tu dirais que ça génère
de Live ouais ouais smash ça génère
beaucoup de hype c'est vachement bien
les tours à Smash
en fait il voulait pas d'âme C8 jusqu'à
chez son roi
mais il y a juste peur bête ou pas
peut-être pas
il veut mettre la dame en F1 en fait
allez il se barre avec le roi c'est
assez sympa comme fin de partie
marrant le roi C3 est-ce qu'il va faire
F6 non
je pensais qu'il tenterait
marrant dame B2 il va faire demain là
attention il peut pas prendre des quatre
il se fait retourner là c'est terrible
ça le mérite d'être amusant
je suis entré dans ma F5 à sa place
quand même
[Musique]
plutôt marrant comme fin de partie mais
ça devrait faire nul
aux échecs le rapport de force et vous
lui passez souvent par exemple à peu de
choses près on connaît déjà le résultat
du match alors c'est dû à deux choses
mer bleue
déjà oui c'est le cas comme les échecs
c'est un jeu quand même qui est très
compliqué il faut tellement d'années
pour devenir fort
c'est les niveaux sont un peu
cristallisés je dirais
donc ça crée un peu ce statu quo à haut
niveau c'est la première chose et
deuxièmement aux échecs on
multiplie et très régulièrement les
formats qui ne permettent pas les
surprises en fait les échecs c'est un
jeu où les organisateurs globalement
mais ça finir de la culture du jeu aime
bien être bien sûr du résultat il va
vraiment être sûr que le meilleur gagne
et
et ce qu'ils font
au delà de ça c'est qu'il crée aussi des
formats ou
la qualité mentale le truc qui se
jouerait sur une seule partie le moment
clutch existe le moins possible
généralement ils font ça et donc c'est
non seulement c'est déjà le cas de base
de par la nature du jeu mais en plus
c'est
exacerbé par les formats des tournois
ce qui est marrant c'est qu'au contraire
smash à cette culture de l'obsèques avec
BO3 BO5 ouais qui est beaucoup plus
marrant pour les spectateurs mais aux
échecs c'est pas notre culture notre
culture c'est de faire des matchs les
plus longs possibles où il y a le moins
de possibilités de surprises
et en quelque sorte ça baisse aussi le
l'importance du côté un peu mental aussi
du truc de réussir à sublimer sur une ou
deux parties qui a une qualité qui est
assez sympa mais c'est voilà c'est pas
notre culture
bah là si tu faisais en 2,7 bo4 il y
aurait beaucoup plus de chances
d'obsèques ou en tout cas le match
serait plus court donc plus à ypan
[Musique]
ce sera un peu compliqué quoi
mais ça chaque jeu à sa culture après
nous comme je disais c'est pas notre
culture
le meilleur gagne je trouve ça bien
mieux que de créer des systèmes
favorisés des surprises
bon après moi je trouve que le côté
match pas trop long ça met en avant
aussi d'autres qualités
je trouve que le côté 7 en fait ça
permet aux joueurs de gérer son match
différemment moi je préfère mais après
comme je disais c'est pas la culture des
échecs
tiens par exemple Djoko qui soit aussi
fort pendant les tailles break je trouve
que c'est une qualité incroyable en fait
d'être capable dans les moments les plus
importants de jouer systématiquement à
ton meilleur niveau
je trouve que c'est quelque chose qui
mérite d'être récompensé
et qui a pas forcément rapport que avec
ton niveau intrinsèque dans le jeu ou
dans le sport
mais c'est une vision différente des
choses et je comprends que certains
préfèrent une certaine préfère l'autre
non mais Koffi oui oui non je comprends
ce que tu veux dire après moi je suis
100% d'accord avec toi mais
après c'est juste pour t'expliquer
pourquoi c'est pas fait parce que ça
paraît complètement illogique de faire
comme on fait mais c'est une question de
culture
ça correspond plus à notre culture en
fait
de jeu
moi j'aime bien le côté mental au
contraire après je l'aime peut-être bien
parce que c'est aussi un de mes points
forts donc on est aussi parfois biaisé
bizarre en fait son idée c'est que sur
fossi c'est la cavalier c'est 5 et c'est
cloué c'est ça l'idée de toi
mais je pense que l'idée c'est tout re 8
qui est pris en B7 ou C4 4 x 6 et du
coup le cavalier enfermé
mais après c'est vrai par exemple si
vous prenez l'exemple de moments clutch
au mental vous avez le tour j'ai 6 de
Ding du coup
en fait moi j'aime bien le côté ou quand
on est sur des matchs plus courts donc
là c'est devenu un boc4 donc on arrive à
la dernière partie
il y a des coûts il y avait pas fou ces
quatre qui gagnait
c'est 4 x 6 et tu reprends F8 mais
c'était quand même avantage
il commence à y avoir des coups un peu
irrationnel qui commence à être fort
parce que Ben pour plein de raisons la
situation de match etc font que on
rentre dans le domaine de l'irrationnel
et moi je kiffe plutôt ça
personnellement
qu'en fait le côté mental il y a plus
que les
au-delà de l'évaluation froide et
mathématiques il y a le côté humain qui
rentrent en jeu et moi c'est ce qui me
fait kiffer quand je regarde du sport en
fait globalement et je trouve que ça
manque cruellement aux échecs
il y a le pion à qui court ah tu vas
peut-être avoir le temps un jour
bon là il la donne même pour récupérer
le pion
il y a tout réussi c'est terrible c'est
une fin de match peut-être ça c'est
gagnant techniquement
et moi j'ai jamais je ne vibre jamais
autant que bah vous rappelez final du
championnat du monde
de Blitz quand Maxime il doit tout
gagner pour revenir moi je trouve je
trouve que dans le la compétition et le
sport en général c'est ça qui est le
plus qui font
pour moi
je trouve que c'est ça qui est beau quoi
il essaye de tenir toutes les cases mais
il doit pas pouvoir
il se fait chasser le roi va rentrer en
ouais bon là c'est ouais
il tourne il tourne à plus 5 autant dire
que c'est une fin de match on va quand
même attendre la pause et regarder les
belettes pour être bien sûr
mais ouais Magnus il a appuyé sur
l'accélérateur
ça fait deux ans que tu stagnes à 1300
tu as l'impression que tu pars
progresser fait beaucoup de tactiques ça
va t'aider
il regarde son tour ouais je crois
surtout que il est il est moins fort
allez on va se faire la petite pause on
revient pour les bolets à tout de suite
les amis
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechesse
ou les titles Tuesday
chase.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présence ciel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition au pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
je suis complètement matrixé par la pub
quoi j'aurais fait du clash royale c'est
terrible dès que tu tombes sur le truc
royal
en fait je suis pas sûr que le
partenariat avec clash royale soit
bénéfique pour chascom
parce que ce qui est sûr c'est quand tu
regardes les échecs tu as envie de faire
du clash royale
c'est terrible ça
allez ça repart pour le bolet on va voir
si Magnus réussit à garder assez
d'intérêt pour continuer à mettre la
pression
fais le système de Londres en tout cas
on va voir allez ça joue
plus c'était dame B3 ou pas on va voir
ça peut rapidement être mathématiquement
terminé donc j'aurai une petite pause
quand même avant le match de Maxime il y
aura pas de
taille break ici c'est impossible de
gagner de 5 points de Bullet je pense
ça va faire plaisir et ça va permettre
de retourner
je suis matrixé par clash royale
maintenant
c'est terrible
j'espère qu'on aura enfin un beau match
j'espère enfin avoir un beau match
je pense que Maxime va écraser Sarine en
tout cas j'espère
faudra pas qu'il se déconcentre autant
contre Google vous cachez vraiment
faible envie de ça
ça c'est une info qu'on avait chopé
avant
ça doit être un des un des 27 50
27 80 les plus faibles de l'histoire en
blitzukash
c'est vraiment pas un bon blitzer
donc c'est un bon match up
d'ailleurs ouais je pense qu'on va
utiliser qu'il aurait pu battre Google
dans le match en Beach je pense qu'il
avait pas complètement tort peut-être
pas complètement raison mais
qui aurait eu ses chances
bon je pense qu'il y a 9 parties au
maximum si Magnus on gagne 3 ça devrait
suffire et là il y a du 4 qui part ouais
Magnus l’écrase mais comme je disais dur
quand les matchs sont déjà pliés c'est
tellement difficile de rester
concentré il fait mal le cavalier va
arriver en E5 c'est cataclysmique
il y a une qui se fait marcher dessus
cavalier F3 cavalier 4 qui arrive
c'est catastrophique
double tour sur la colonne des le
cavalier qui va arriver en H4 ou le pion
il va lui ouvrir le roi sur case blanche
et ça va terminer le boulot
menace tu reprends des 5 c'est fait dam
prend 8 dame G6 reprend des 5 c'est
terminé ado raté par
Ariane mais il était aux abois
il y a jugé trois malheureusement
d'un tour des 8 et dame
quelque part allez ça fait ça fait quoi
ça fait 6 points d'écart maintenant
le score qui enfle et le suspense
qui explose
mais le suspense qui disparaît
à tout jamais
vraiment trop fort Magnus et ouais il a
aussi l'emprise mentale sur Yann
G6 ouais c'est ouais c'est terrible
c'est horrible parce que fait Yann il a
lâché dans la tête
il a il a lâché dans la tête à
il a lâché dans la tête à ça c'est comme
ça
et ouais dans ce format là c'est
vraiment
c'est vraiment difficile
j'essaie de faire marcher tout reprendre
avec des cinq suffit
tu en prends trois tours
allez le match est quasiment fini même
mathématiquement
ça fait plaisir
et une victoire de Minus tranquille
Yann qui aura pas des mérités il a
quasiment fait le match parfait quoi
c'est ça le pire
mais ouais c'est vraiment un trop
mauvais match up
l'emprise du Scandinave est trop forte
ça va être chaud
les joueurs qui sont obligés de jouer
jusqu'à au moins 10 minutes de la fin
ils n'ont absolument pas le droit
d'abandonner
même si
ils ne peuvent plus revenir
en belette le minus se mange après si le
match avait été plus serré ça aurait
peut-être été un tout petit peu
différent le scénario
je sais pas
honnêtement je ne sais pas
quoi qu'il en soit
il est très facile
pourquoi
être sûr en cas de revenir c'est pour
être sûr que les matchs durent à peu
près 4 heures max games
c'est pour pouvoir contrôler le timing
des matchs
ouais Magnus est trop au dessus
ce qui va sauver partir dans ils peuvent
pas ils sont vraiment obligés de jouer
jusqu'au bout et là puis on prend
cavalier prend le roi est trop mal
ça et on va rentrer dans l'humiliant bon
c'est ça qui fait plaisir
ça nous met très très bien
ouais qu'est-ce qu'il est fort Magnus le
fruit mais après c'est facile il joue
dans il joue dans dans des chaussons là
ouais comme quoi Yann avait jamais
aucune chance de gagner ce match quand
on voit le Bullet le Bullet est fait
quand même parti prépondérante du truc
et quand on voit les cartes de niveau en
belette même si ça a été un peu
différent dans un match serré aurait tu
aurais-tu tu le fallu que le match soit
serré
il y avait pas il y avait pas de monde
en fait le match était plié d'avance
avant de commencer mamie l'avait déjà
perdu mais il ne le savait pas nous on
le savait par contre
ça fait ça fait 8 points et là je crois
que c'est mathématiquement termine ado
magnifique match quand même entre les
deux hommes on a vu un spectacle
remarquable aujourd'hui
on a une nouvelle fois atteint des
sommets de niveau de jeu côté Magnus
Yann obligé de s'incliner mais mais quel
classico
quel classico aujourd'hui
il ne le savait pas encore mais il était
déjà mort c'est exactement ça si elle
bleu c'est en fait avant le début du
match il avait déjà perdu en réalité
nous le savions mais lui ne le savait
pas là maintenant Magnus qui s'amuse qui
joue
des parties un peu rocambolesques
est-ce que le est-ce que ce match était
plus beau que le franc Uruguay d'hier
il y a il y a match
il y a pas fou prends à l'intermédiaire
non
mais c'est sain qui se prend ouais bon
il en peut plus Yann
heureusement qu'il a encore un coup pour
s'en sortir mais il en peut plus
il a 25 secondes d'écart il se fait il
se fait il se fait manger voilà ça là il
va s'en sortir mais
il devrait réussir à s'en sortir mais
bon
je sais pas ce qu'il veut la Magnus
OK
intéressant de cette finale pour le coup
menace ma t-en un quand même attention à
Surger 5 il va acheter 5 G6
il fait foi F1
et là il va faire une carreau
non quand même pas il est un peu plus
respectueux qui Caro
il a pas réussi à avoir le manque de
classe
habituel du Karu Magnus même quand il
essaye il y arrive pas
c'est pas de bol
mais qu'un 7 c'est une partie fin qui
leur approche de la victoire non puisque
la victoire elle est déjà empochée c'est
juste une partie de plus de jouets
genre tempo 30 secondes ouais il Carole
aurait fait
voilà c'est une partie qui se passe
encore plutôt bien pour les blanches je
pense
perd l'intérêt du match
c'est drôle qui va nous faire ouais
après là le match est terminé donc il y
a plus d'intérêt ni pour l'un ni pour
l'autre quoi juste
pourquoi il faut que les matchs
durent environ 4 heures c'est que les
règles du match font qui dure 4 heures
il y a pas d'obligation quoi que ce soit
c'est juste que ça va durer quatre
heures quoi
alors la jauge qui s'emballe sur qui que
Yann vient de jouer de mauvais coups là
il a donné des pions
il a dû rater quelque chose c'était quoi
qui gagnait
est-ce que ça va faire nul ou pas cette
partie c'est un peu le seul suspense
il va essayer de gagner à H4 en tout cas
Magnus
pour tuer encore un peu plus ce match
plus de coup là
ça c'est une tourelle il a plus les
couilles
allez ça fait 9 points d'écart
encore 16 minutes de supplice
il n'a pas les couilles il n'a pas les
coups
c'est pas très agréable de jouer quand
le match est complètement terminé mais
ça fait ça fait déjà un moment
mais alors Yann commence juste à
regarder d'autres fenêtres en fait ouais
ok j'avais pas j'avais pas capté le
délire
je sais pas ce qu'il a ouvert mais il a
ouvert un truc
c'est pas mal joué
non si l'abandonne on a plus de 4
minutes de supplice sinon encore un
quart d'heure
on espère
5 minutes
c'est pas bizarre c'est 19h là ça va
pouvoir on va avoir comme une petite
pause là ça fera pas 9h30 ça fera que
8h30 c'est cool
elle va faire plaisir la pause
sauf si oui qu'il est pas abandonné
ouais ce qui ferait mal
ce qui ferait très très mal
il va la perdre
ouais ça s'appelle vous prend un raté
OK
allez ça fait encore un point
ça fait 10 points d'écart ouais ouais en
fait c'est fou il y avait il y a jamais
eu en fait il devrait commencer par le 1
+ 1 au moins on saurait si un match ou
pas
terrible
sur un point il veut 4 je suppose
ça c'est une dame en un
mais bon
la musique comme ça parce qu'il y a plus
d'intérêt pour les parties
Naruto tout ça ben en vrai
c'est vrai que peut-être qu'il y a un
épisode de Naruto serait pas
désintéressant pendant ce match j'aurais
bien regardé
tu me diras j'étais deux épisodes au
hasard c'était 4 cataclysmique
déjà je comprends pas comment il court
après je crois qu'il a regardé la
pendule donc il doit il doit vouloir
abandonner le match
bon ça va s'arrêter ici on va pouvoir
suivre une nouvelle en paix
quand même
Magnus qui se met à faire n'importe
quoi
et on espère qu'il abandonne
c'est nul est-ce que Yann va proposer
là c'est nul
est-ce que Yann va abandonner
non le supplice va continuer encore 7
minutes
un peu bizarre mais il a pas abandonné
terrible
ça me bute quand même ce truc
j'arrive pas à comprendre en fait
après je crois qu'ils oublient ou juste
ils veulent pas abandonner pour pas
paraître pour passer pour des pleutres
non je pense qu'il se dit que abandonné
c'est pleutre
c'est bien triste la fin du match là
cavalier G8 ouais c'est
Dame
des 8 quand même
6 ouais
nous on a qu'à attendre ça finisse de
toute façon
Maxime sera à 19h
j'espère un match intéressant le
précédent de Maxime a pas été ouais quoi
que victoire de Maxime sur un match même
si le SI
ennuyeux avec le précédent on prend
on espère que ça ça s'éternise pas plus
qui prend aussi si votre T4 c'est bien
joué ça
ah il abandonne il reste encore deux
et on va pouvoir faire une pause
un problème de serveur sur le remake
j'espère que va arrêter la pendule pour
pas perdre la moindre seconde de match
il y a une qui est juste en train de
naviguer sur
sur son navigateur ils arrivent pas à
rejouer
donc le match il va avoir une petite
pause là
c'est ça le chronomètre est arrêté
le temps que Yann voilà a réussi sa
repartir
il va rester encore deux parties quand
même
ce serait dommage
on va voir est-ce que ça peut être la
dernière partie ou pas c'est plus ça la
question maintenant
c'est plus ça la question maintenant
il reste plus qu'une 45
c'est un nomade ouais ouais il y a pas
eu de
a bien commencé mais Magnus dès qu'il a
accéléré il a gagné trop fort
soit le truc c'est qu'il est moins fort
que Yann mais le match up puis moins
négatif moins défavorable
c'est trop
il n'y a pas de dame G7 tu reprends
c'est pas si clair
et une dernière pour la route
du point d'écart
un peu donc ouais on sera de retour à
19h
il y a une 19 fois parce que je me suis
trompé
de toute façon vous voyez bien le score
en dessous enfin ça va ça fait ça fait
ça fait une heure et demie que le match
il est terminé
pas grave mais bon c'est long pour tout
le monde
de toute façon on le sait bien que le
match il finisse fait 1h30 c'est plus
ado
sera une chance ouais il aura une
meilleure chance que Yann il peut faire
quelque chose
si Magnus est vraiment très concerné il
gagnera mais si Magnus est pas en super
forme il peut se faire contrer
bien joué
beaucoup trop fort le M beaucoup
beaucoup trop fort
E
allez c'est bon
c'en est assez 21 points d'écart les
amis on va passer terniser parce qu'on
va récupérer l'énergie pour pour le
prochain match je vous dis à dans trois
quart d'heure pour
mvel Sarine